good morning John John a few days ago
you listed three reasons why Chewbacca
shouldn't be President or couldn't be
President since he's not a citizen and
he is also dead but she left out an
important reason that was brought to my
attention by shark AI Jones and I have
to let you know having Chewbacca leading
the Chewie Solo ticket presents a
problem because Chewbacca owes a life
debt to Han Solo Chewie was sentenced to
death for doing something I don't
remember what and Han Solo saved him and
so in Wookiee law Chewie now has to do
everything he can to keep Han Solo alive
which creates a problem if there is ever
an attempt on Han Solo's life because
then you would have the president
jumping in front of the bullet or the
blaster bolt to save the vice
president's life which just seems wrong
so I just want to bring that up there's
an advertisement paid for by the
citizens of Mon Calamari for an Akbar
Calrissian ticket and that is the fact
that they're using to try and divide us
on the Chewie solo idea not really
important though maybe we should move on
more important as far as I'm concerned
just to give you my two cents here's
five fake it I hit my guitar on that
video you made a little while ago about
seven out so there are two ways that we
can make money there's the
advertisements and then there's the sell
and stuff and I like both of them
because they let us spend more time on
our videos making them 126 percent
better than the videos we made in March
of 2006 if you don't believe me go watch
so let us take the advertisements first
know as far as advertisements go we have
no control over what you see and we
actually don't even know what's there I
have no idea what's in that space over
there and before you click that little X
I didn't know it was down here either
that's all complete mystery to me in
fact you could pause your video right
now and leave a comment saying what
those advertisements are that would be
really helpful because then we would
have some idea of what was going on the
other way that we make money is by
selling stuff which we infinitely prefer
to advertisements because I kind of feel
like advertisements are a little bit
dirty Jon you sell books I sell CDs we
sell t-shirts but that's not something
that's outside of what nerdfighteria is
ever since Helen Hunt part of me on
YouTube has been writing songs and
forever part of you on YouTube has been
writing books of course Jon you're right
no one should ever feel obligated to buy
something I know what it's like to be
young and poor I used to save my lunch
money by eating other people's leftovers
in the school cafeteria yeah that's
right the part of the cafeteria food
that the other kids wouldn't eat that's
what I ate so that I could save money to
buy CDs kids don't do that do not risk
getting a disease to buy my CD do not do
that
I am really into the YouTube thing I
love the idea that my friends on YouTube
might be able to make some money doing
it so when I see stuff like this I want
it and I have to have it this is a CD
that would not exist without YouTube in
like 17 different ways it's a
collaborative project between two
youtubers fall/autumn distro allen will
stuff go and Tom Milsom hexa chordal who
is one of the most musicians making
music on YouTube today they decided to
make this album and they did it 100%
without ever seeing each other it's this
beautiful wonderful thing that would
never exist without YouTube and there's
only six tracks but it's only six
dollars and I'm really happy to be a
part of it and so I don't feel bad for
telling you this is awesome and hoping
that some of you were going to buy it
and at the end of this video you'll be
able to click through to see an amazing
music video that was done for one of
these songs I mean let's be honest we
love making YouTube videos we would do
this with or without the money but being
able to dedicate more time to these
videos being able to do more cool things
like truth or fail and make real good
studio produce music that's the kind of
stuff that we wouldn't be able to do if
we didn't consider this part of our work
so despite the fact that a lot of people
who my hands look huge he's gonna do
this so despite the fact that a lot of
people respond to your video saying a
let they kind of feel like money is
dirty and they'll trust us to be good
people I just wanted to give my two
cents on the selling out thing that is
all bye bye
you can't put into words just how she
made him out he muggles all the best in
you cut
he's edited harm was a favorite work of
on surprising every day